hallo mein name ist programm meine damen
und herren juli und ich haben uns mal
wieder gedacht dass wir zum ersten mal
einen spielraum ist es ein schwarzer
lädt gerade jude spielten sich heute zum
ersten mal welche spielt black ops 4
das neue black ops vier von call of duty
das spiel nämlich seit einiger zeit
verfügbar für playstation xbox pc et
cetera und das tier liegen rum jetzt auf
dem boden
nice oder bis der zug nach köln die
macher von dem neuen black ops haben
mich gefragt hätte luca möchtest du
nicht ein video dazu machen und da habe
ich gesagt ja klar gern
deswegen wird er um werbe video
eingeblendet bz macht dazu quasi gar
nicht primären video sondern juli spielt
ja heute zum ersten mal die erste runde
spiele ich jetzt allerdings im juli
einfach mal zu zeigen worum es hier geht
also wir fliegen hier rum mit
helikoptern und können jetzt aufdrücken
dann springen wir nämlich raus mit
unserem wingsuit hier vorne machen
einfach unseren fallschirm auf landen
hier vorne und jule jetzt ist es quasi
so ist halt ein battle royale modus dass
wir uns jetzt erstmal sachen suchen
müssen und jetzt geht es quasi darum
dass ich gegner finde und diese gegner
quasi eliminieren kann man hier vorne
liegt sogar noch eine andere
ich bin tot ja ich habe es besser nur
wenige minuten später sehr gut
jetzt geht's los jetzt geht's los jetzt
musst du bereit sein
dann fliegen ammann stand weise jule ist
jetzt in landet hier vorne an dem
waschbecken am strand an der toilette
dann schauen wir auch da drin
irgendwelchen genau da ist die toilette
da kannst du mal hingehen jetzt kannst
du theoretisch mal auf dem rücken eben
genau jetzt siehst du dass du sehr sehr
weit in die zone laufen muss also ich
finde schon krass wenn man halt so
überlegt was das für riesige maps sind
die dort einfach verbaut und kann man
hier zum beispiel eine straße der
linkskurve nach links da oben links
dingsda usd weiter rechts das einfach
nie auf den berg wird zeigen dass man da
sind also ich find's klasse die
mittlerweile das leveldesign oder
webdesign da mittlerweile aufgebaut ist
weil das sie es sieht einfach schön
ausfindig rein was hier nicht schön es
ist juli spielweise
ja leute ja ich habe euch geheimnis
gemacht mittlerweile ist julia gerade
bauer geworden
doch mal ins wasser da kannst du dich
ein bisschen abkühlen und ein bisschen
schwimmen jan eismasse dass jude
der ist gott nimm das 99 fahr schnell
schnell stellt zwar ein heldenhafter tod
also jude nächste runde hier
ich würde sagen drücken wir jetzt direkt
schon genau
ja und jetzt guckt nach unten und dann
wege drückten dann bist du gleich ganz
schnell auf dem boden durch und auf der
anderen zumeist noch gar nicht bereit
das unfälle wenn die einen direkt
abschließen also universe haben uns die
erste und die zweite runde gezeigt dass
man nicht sterben muss jedoch vielleicht
mal so ein kleines gebäude hier am rand
irgendwie oder so da wirst du zwar nicht
die allerbesten sachen finden aber ich
denke dass wir schon aufgemacht wir
wissen jetzt natürlich nicht so die
allerbesten waffen finden nicht so die
allerbesten aufsätze keine ahnung was
aber hier haben beispielsweise schon
eine panzerung
da wirst du nicht so schnell dann
getötet schule bewegt weil du ja gerade
gestorben ist weil du jemanden nicht
geboxt hast dann würde ich sagen zu
nehmen jetzt das gut klappt doch gut so
jule jetzt würde ich sagen rückt man
auch direkt bei dem musik helfe ich
jetzt mal so ein bisschen genauer schaut
mal auf dem boden
und so muss dies allerdings machen wir
machen ich mache jetzt die maus und dem
was die tastatur soll ich würd sagen wir
fliegen mal hier vorne hin halt du
weiter wege drückt die ganze zeit genau
wie ihnen ihr hin und gehen jetzt in den
hangar genau laufen genau das ist mein
gott zurückgedrückt rüdiger zeit und
laufen weiter bei der lauffenmühle
weiter laufen hier fünf runden lang hat
die schule jetzt hier gespielt bzw
zugeguckt erfahrungen gesammelt und
jetzt schauen wir mal ob das ganze sich
gelohnt hat ein paar schicken den späten
jubel nach hinten das ist ein molotow
cocktail
nein mein gott du hast fünf leben jule
du hast einfach ein molotow cocktail auf
dich selbst geworfen gerade
weil am blut das wird auf jeden fall
eine klasse runde ich meine ihr müsst
euch vorstellen so das spiel des jahres
mit dem krassesten battle royale modus
und dann gibt's juli schaut sich da die
waldgegend mal ein bisschen genauer an
besuch doch mal nach vorne zu der
tankstelle hin zu laufen und schauen ob
da vielleicht ein hawaii sind nicht so
spritzen oder so noch heute liegen
gelassen hat weil die katze in die tram
quasi und dann ja dann damit quasi
wieder fit erstmal ja schauen wir mal
wer dich getötet hat aber gut gespielt
das war auf jeden fall klasse an der
stelle würden wir das heutige wieder ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren die leute von cod mich einfach
gefragt herr luca wir haben die videos
gesehen schule zum ersten mal spielen
wir sind nicht auch mal zum ersten mal
unser neues cod spielen und ich sagte
mir natürlich mega geiles spiel checken
hat allerdings gnadenlos versagt
falls ihr allerdings das spiel möglich
machen und wollte sich das ganze
eventuell noch mal auf einem kanal
spieler dann als gerne einen daumen hoch
bei diesem video da und jetzt kommt das
auto
[Musik]
ein